[techno music plays]
[keyboard keys click]
>>Male: Go ahead.
>>Joe: Hello, welcome once again to Android
Developer Office Hours.
I'm Joe Malin, your moderator, next to me
is Trevor Johns.
>>Trevor: Hello everyone.
>>Joe: One of our developer engineers.
We also have Alex Lucas in the studio.
Daniel Pham is our Engineer.
And we have a special guest today Chirag,
who is going to be talking about Google Play
services API and what you can use it to do
with.
Or something like that.
[Trevor laughs]
>>Joe: That was flaky.
OK, Chirag, please.
>>Chirag: Hi, my name is Chirag Shah and I'm
a developer programs engineer on Google Plus.
I'm here to talk about the brand new Google
Plus APIs and Coolpix services which help
you create a more personalized experience
for your users with the native Plus One button
and Sign in button.
So let's jump into the Plus One button.
Generally the plus one button offers a way
for users to recommend content within your
application.
With the new APIs in Google Play Services.
you can integrate a native plus one button
in your app.
[Loud chime]
>>Chirag: So how do you do this?
First, include the Plus One button in your
layouts.
Next integrate the Plus client object in the
life cycle of your activity.
This means you'll initialize the plus client
object in your on create handler and then
call up plus client dot connect during your
on start handler and finally call plus client
dot disconnect in your on stop handler.
So why do we do this?
During your on start handler, you'll call
plus client dot connect which establishes
a connection between your application and
Google Play services.
And we call disconnect to terminate the connection
and just to be a good citizen and have a decent
battery life.
Finally, initialize the plus one button in
your on create handler and plus the url that
should be plus one when initializing the plus
one button.
So now let's jump into the sign in button.
Have you ever tried to enter a username and
password on the mobile device?
It's really difficult.
[chuckles] The sign in with Google plus button
authenticates the user and manages OAuth two
dot 0 flow and helps simplify the integration
with Google plus APIs.
Furthermore users will get a single sign on
experience and won't need to reenter their
Google credentials to use your application.
The steps to integrate the sign in button
are very similar to integrating the plus one
button.
First, you'll include the plus sign in button
in your layout, next integrate the plus client
object in the life cycle of your activity
like you did before.
But when initializing the plus client object,
you'll pass an array of OAuth 2 dot 0s code,
which basically declare the types of information
you're requesting.
So let's take a look at what we just talked
about.
What does the plus one button and sign in
button actually look like on a device?
So here this is the
Google plus sample application we have on
the Google SDK manager.
>>Dan: Hey Chirag, this is engineer Dan, can
you make sure that the connection on the device
is all the way plugged in?
I'm not getting anything out of the screen
right now.
[pause] I think it's the power cord may have
got unplugged out the MHL connector so make
sure that the-
>>Trevor: Yeah, MHL is not plugged in.
[Pause] [whispering indistinctly off camera]
>>Chirag: Having a bit of technical difficulties
in projecting the phone.
>>Trevor: The fun of doing things live.
>>Joe: Right.
Someday we'll learn how to use our equipment
properly.
[chuckles]
>>Trevor: Yeah, you can leave that plugged
in, there is signal getting down to the box.
>>Dan: Unplug the MHL connector from the phone
and plug it back in.
[pause]
>>Dan: Swear to God [inaudible] in there too.
[Trevor laughs]
>>Joe: Yes?
No?
>>Dan: No luck.
>>Joe: Still nothing.
>>Dan: Alright guys why don't we move on?
>>Trevor: Alright, yeah let's move to Plan
B.
>>Chirag: OK so, basically you can emulate
what we've done here by going to developers
dot Google dot com slash plus, slash mobile,
slash Android.
From there you'll see some instructions instructing
you to grab the Google Plus SDK within the
Google Android SDK manager and you'll be able
to run the sample application yourself.
>>Trevor: We'll see if we can--.
Pass the phone over here, let me see if I
can demo the sample app live for folks.
Let's see, we'll unhook this cable.
So Dan, can you get a camera on me by any
chance?
Let's hold it up here.
For those of you watching, let's see if we
can get this focused.
Alright
>>Dan: You're good.
>>Trevor: Yeah, so Chirag if you wanna come
over and play with the floating phone.
>>Chirag: OK thank you Trevor.
You can press sign in here and as you can
see here, this is what the Google Plus sign
in button looks like.
So we'll press the sign in button and now
it's going to ask you to grant access to the
sample application and the permissions are
know who you are on Google, and send your
activity to your private Google Plus history.
I'm gonna press allow.
And now we're signed in.
So now let's take a look at the plus one button.
Here you can see the native Plus one button
in various configurations; small, medium,
tall standard and with - in my annotation--
demonstrating who else Plus one knew.
We can un-plus one'd it here- my finger.
Here you can see the plus one dialogue and
it says "you publicly plus one'd this' and
it shows your name and the application you
plus one'd it from.
And that's about it.
Thank you, Trevor.
>>Trevor: Hopefully you could make that out,
everyone watching it on the camera.
I know it's a little bit blurry.
Making the best- making do with what you can
here.
Right.
>>Chirag: And that's it.
>>Trevor: Alright I think that's it for Chirag.
>>Joe: Thank you, Chirag.
>>Trevor: Yeah, thank you.
>>Joe: Great, our next guest is Tim Bray and
what is Tim gonna be talking about?
>>Trevor: Tim is going to be talking about
it looks like OAuth, correct?
Are you there, Tim?
>>Tim: That's right.
>>Joe: Tim?
>>Tim: I'm here!
>>Trevor: There you are.
>>Joe: So you're gonna be talking about OAuth,
is that correct?
>>Tim: Well, I'm going to be talking about
OAuth in the context of Google Play services.
Yeah.
>>Joe: OK, great.
Go ahead Tim.
>>Tim: Take it away.
So anyhow, so Google play services started
rolling out last week and one of the big goodies
that's in there is access to OAuth two stuff.
Now, the other big goodie was the Google plus
stuff that Chirag just showed you and in fact,
if you look underneath the code that he was
running, the OAuth code was also being used
to handle the authorization stuff.
And we're gonna be using it for lots of other
stuff.
So the problem is that OAuth 2 is a great
big messy complicated standard and that's
gonna give us a whole set of issues around
accessing resources online.
It's big and messy and complicated.
And OAuth 2 is hard to understand and you
shouldn't have to.
So what we're trying to do is make that goodness
available with a reasonably sane tractable
API.
And the upside's pretty good.
The upside is nobody ever has to type a password.
Like Chirag said, that sucks.
It's really hard to type passwords on mobile
devices.
But even though they don't have to have a
password they still get good security, they
always get prompted by the system in whether
they want to give access via their email address
and they only get prompted once.
If they change their minds they can revoke
that later.
And it really works pretty well.
It's a much better user experience.
Now if you're using a Google API like Calendar,
YouTube or Google Plus there's a nice Java
language library that just takes care of all
this stuff for you.
But if you wanna work on a lower level, at
the rest level, you're doing HTTP gets and
puts; you can also do that directly.
I find actually that the Google plus API works
really terrifically well at the rest level.
Just doing you know, gets to pull JSON and
deal with those.
So the way it works is you look at the SDK
that came with Google play services and there's
a class in there called Google auth util and
you work it and eventually it gives you a
thing called a token, which is just a string,
a bearer token which is just a string that
you put in a HTTP header.
You do that and you magically get access to
your stuff, any stuff you're entitled to have
on Google Plus.
Anybody out there who already knows what OAuth
2 is gonna be wondering about token expiration
and refreshing and so on.
But don't worry.
The Google client services library just takes
care of all that for you.
And it's a little bit complicated because
it's asynchronous, because when you use OAuth
it's quite possible the phone's gonna have
to go out and prompt the person to say you
know is it OK to use your address for this
and then there's gonna be lots of network
traffic.
So you totally can't ever do that on the IO
thread and, in fact, if you need to prompt
it'll be- do an attempt that you'll have to
launch and you know act on it in your on activity
result method and so on and so forth.
And there's a little bit of other extra work
as well which that is if you're using OAuth
2, the system, the server side wants to know
what app it's talking to.
So you'll have to go and register your app.
There's a thing called the API console that
you'd do that.
Just type Google API console into Google and
it'll take you straight there.
So as I said, there's a little bit of extra
work but the upside is really good.
Higher security, lower irritation and-
[Inaudible chatter over Tim talking]
>>Tim: Finally, I want to say something about
[inaudible] triggers, that's the story up
to now.
But working on some other goodies.
If you think about it, most Android apps are
hybrid which is to say they have a mobile
app and they'll have a web back end where
it provides things like persistence and shared
user data and so on.
And you’ve got an interesting authentication
problem there which is how does the backend
know what app it is talking to it and what
person it's talking to?
And you don’t want the person to be typing
in a password just so that your own server
knows that it's talking to your own app.
So we've got some stuff coming down the road
that will make further mileage out of the
Google play services OAuth stuff.
So this is really a interesting time to be
working on identity stuff and I think that
with you know, by adopting the stuff and doing
a little extra work you can, first of all
boost security and secondly really improve
the general user experience that you're offered.
So that's the OAuth story.
>>Joe: Great, thank you very much Tim.
Do we have any questions online or coming
through and anything in Google plus on this?
OK Alright.
So if there aren't, we'll leave the lines
open, if you've got any questions either type
them in or get into the Hangout.
>>Trevor: Either way I think they'll have
to get onto the Hangout.
>>Joe: That's true.
Yes.
>>Trevor: Yes.
>>Joe: So if you have questions, get into
the Hangout, ask the question and we'll get
to you as soon as we can.
Meanwhile, we're gonna move to Google Moderator
and take some questions off of there.
>>Trevor: Yep, so these were questions submitted
before the show and voted on by viewers.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Trevor: So the first question is from Palo
Alto, California from a name I can't quite
read but, do you wanna go ahead and read that,
Joe?
>>Joe: Yeah sure.
"I'm using loaders from support library however
I found when the device is rotated the activity
gets recreated and inits the existing loader,
but on load finish never gets called.
Some say it's a bug and support lib.
What's the solution or the work around?"
>>Trevor: OK, so I looked into this a little
bit before the show and so yeah, the issue
in question here is specific to the support
library and exactly what was described.
When on pause is called on load finished is
not getting called for the loader and this
is not the behavior exhibited by the system
frameworks.
And because of that that pretty much says,
yeah, this is a bug.
It's something that we need to address in
the support library.
I'll go ahead and make sure the team that
works on that is aware of it and I will try
and get it fixed in there for you for the
next version.
Unfortunately I'm not aware of a work around
off the top of my head on this so, for now,
I think you'll just need to be real careful
whenever your app is using the support library
in loaders and you fall into this particular
case.
But we'll try to improve it for the next release.
>>Joe: Great.
Thank you very much.
Next question out of Moderator is from David
in Utah.
"I've implemented standard lock screen controls
via remote control client; the controls don't
appear if the screen is locked while media
is paused.
Is that a feature?
Is there a way to get around it?"
>>Trevor: I believe it is a feature because
when your media is not playing, the user probably
wants to see- or doesn't want the media controls
up.
That's sort of the way most of the media services
in Android work.
Whenever media playback is paused since there
is no quit command anywhere in the system,
we just have to assume that your application
is- treat your application as if it's no longer
running regardless of what's going on under
the covers.
And that gives the correct user experience.
Now as far as ways to get around, I can't
really think of one.
Cause again this is actually by design, again
if you're not actually playing sound your
media player shouldn’t be visible to the
user.
So I think it's working as intended.
>>Joe: Right, I would say certainly on the
lock screen, that's true.
>>Trevor: Yeah, we've added- for the notifications-
>>Joe: Notifications, right.
>>Trevor: That also used to be actually the
way it worked, too.
On recent builds we've added the ability to
have extra controls up there-
>>Joe: Right.
Yeah.
>>Trevor: Like the close button, things like
that.
But that's only in the most recent builds.
>>Joe: Yep.
I agree.
The next question is from Jason Robinson in
Tennessee.
"I'm writing a camera app that captures both
pictures and video, when I start capturing
video with a Galaxy S 3, the preview display
turns to garbage.
It works and looks fine on other devices"
There's a link here to a stack overflow question.
>>Trevor: So in general, whenever you see
something that's not working as intended on
one device and it works fine everywhere else,
that's what we call a compatibility bug.
It's something we definitely take very serious
and for those of you who are long time watchers
of the show we've mentioned both the CTS and
CDD but as a recap the CDD is the compatibility
definition document which defines how everything
should work on Android.
And the Compatibility Test Suite is the set
of automated tests that actually- that we
run on every new device to verify that it
actually meets the requirements set forth
in the CDD.
If you see a bug like this, that likely means
there is a gap in our CTS coverage so something
somehow didn't make it through, wasn't tested
for in the automated tests.
The good news is all of that is open source
and is very easy to go and modify and add
additional tests so if you are a developer
and most people watching probably are, we
definitely like to encourage you to go and
submit new patches and add in any missing
coverage into the CTS.
That being said, maybe you're busy, you are
of course welcome to file bugs and we'll go
ahead and add update the CTS as well.
Our issue tracker is at b dot Android dot
com just let us know as much detail as you
can, which specific devices you're having
issues with and our engineers will go ahead
and triage that and update our test suite
as appropriate.
>>Joe: Great, thank you.
Did you happen to look at stack overflow?
>>Trevor: I did and it looks really actually
bad.
[laughs]
>>Joe: Did anybody respond and say they'd
run into the same or make any more comments?
>>Trevor: No, it's just the question right
now.
So I can go ahead and hold it up on screen
here.
This is what the developer is seeing on a
normal device and then this is what they're
seeing on that one particular device.
>>Joe: Well, that's not good.
>>Trevor: This is something that's definitely
broken on that phone.
If I didn't know better, I'd say the phone
itself was damaged but I imagine the camera
probably works fine in other apps.
>>Joe: The only thing I can think of is that
someone in stack over flow land can try and
see if they can reproduce the problem and
see if it's a phone or a class of phones.
>>Trevor: Yeah, my guess is it's probably
something, some odd bug in the camera driver
on that device.
>>Joe: Yeah.
Please file a bug.
>>Trevor: Yes.
>>Joe: And if you've got time to work on the
CTS and the CDD please do that as well, that
would be very helpful.
Daniel anything out there in Hangout land
yet?
No.
OK We'll move on then.
X the unknown, asks "Can you clarify the main
differences in use case between account manager
and Google play services?"
>>Trevor: OK, Tim or Chirag, I think one of
you probably be the best people to ask this.
>>Joe: Yeah, absolutely.
>>Trevor: Do either wanna take this?
>>Tim: Can I speak to that?
This is Tim, can you hear me?
>>Joe: Yeah.
>>Tim: OK so account manager is older, it's
been around for a while.
And it is, as the name suggests, an account
manager and it manages all sorts of accounts.
If I pull up the accounts in my preferences
on my own phone, I see accounts from Dropbox,
Google, Twoogle, Twitter and so on.
So it's sort of a general purpose for apps
to stash accounts and for people to use them.
It turns out that account manager has always
had the ability of generating tokens of various
sorts but it was never really very fully worked
out and never really became popular.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Tim: And Google play services has a new
class called Google auth util, I was talking
about, it's specifically aimed at doing some
extra OAuth magic, specifically with Google
accounts because that's what it's called Google
accounts services.
So if you want to look up the accounts that
are on the phone, ask the apps user for access
to them that kind of stuff, account manager
is still what you wanna use.
If you wanna do special magic with OAuth 2
and Google accounts, the new stuff in Google
play services is what you need.
>>Joe: OK.
Chirag, any additions to that?
>>Chirag: And with the plus sign in button,
it wraps around the complexities of taking
in account on the phone and granting access
from the user.
So if you have three or four accounts on the
phone, Google plus sign in button will first
prompt the user to select an account and then
ask them for authorization.
>>Joe: Right.
Uses the Google accounts though?
>>Chirag: Yes, this would be Google accounts.
>>Joe: OK
>>Chirag: And it would take care of the magic
for you.
>>Joe: OK, great.
We'll move to the next question from Daniel
"I have a strange problem here that puzzles
me.
After rotating the device, an edit text dot
get texting on pause returns text that was
never assigned to it.
When pausing from back key, it doesn't happen.
I have no idea what's going on here."
>>Trevor: Alright, Alex have you had a chance
to take a look into this at all?
>>Alex: I looked at the stack overflow error
but I wasn't able to see what was going on.
In the example that he uses-
>>Trevor: By the way Alex, you might want
to stand up and hop on camera.
>>Alex: Right, actually be on camera.
>>Joe: Oh what the heck.
>>Alex: I prefer being a you know, disembodied
voice, but OK
>>Joe: And..
>>Alex: Stand on the X?
OK So-
>>Trevor: There he is.
>>Alex: Hello.
>>Trevor: How'd that happen?
>>Joe: Magic of TV.
>>Alex: Within this specific example what's
happening is the text box has a default value
of hello world and they type z-z-z into the
box.
So it's hello the world z-z-z, rotate the
device, call get text on that edit box and
what they see is just the z-z-z so just the
part that was concatenated to the default
value.
I'm absolutely puzzled by what would be causing
the behavior, actually.
>>Trevor: OK, we'll look into it a bit more
and see if we can get an answer and update
the stack overflow for you.
So just keep an eye on there, we'll also provide
an update through next week's broadcast to
let everyone watching, who is not following
the stack overflow, know what the resolution
was.
Alright, let's move on.
>>Joe: Great, thanks.
From A.S.
Hughes in San Luis Obispo, "My app's sqlite
db has more than 1 megabyte of data, it's
a protobuf, and the single row's blob column
and cursor crashes when trying to retrieve
it.
Now that cursor has a 1 megabyte limit but
my app has been in use for a while, how do
I retrieve the user's data?"
>>Trevor: Oh boy.
[laughs] That's gonna be a bit of a problem.
So, general guidance for working with databases
of what using the blob storage types they
tend- it's not just an Android thing, over
and over again I've seen developers on all
platforms shoot themselves in the foot by
trying to store really large things in the
databases that's not really designed to do
so.
A better option in pretty much every single
instance in every single instance where you're
tempted to use a blob is just to write the
blob to a regular file somewhere on disk and
store- store the file name, store a [unintelligible]
file in the database-
>>Joe: Right.
>>Trevor: -and then just go and load it as
a standard file.
Now getting back to the original question
is how do you recover from this once you've-
it's grown beyond one megabyte?
Unfortunately all of the sqlite methods in
Android, that at least I'm aware of will return
a cursor.
And I'm also not familiar with any ways to
go and just request a range within that blob.
So I think if you really want to go and solve
this problem, you're going to have to go and
grab the source code sqlite, compile it into
your application and then access it directly
without using cursors.
Keep in mind that you do have to watch out
for the devices own memory limit.
You're going to be loading this blob into
memory essentially and you don’t want to
go to streaming out to disk as quickly as
possible to go and avoid running out of memory.
It's going to be ugly.
I'm sorry that I don’t have a better answer
for you, I really wish I did.
But I think that's pretty much- or the other
option, too, is there's the nuclear approach
you can tell users that they're gonna have
to wipe their data.
In some limited cases it actually is OK, very
limited.
Most apps I think that actually is a pretty
cruddy user experience.
Especially most apps that would have one megabyte
files attached to them.
So I think pretty much what you're gonna have
to do is compile a custom copy of sqlite into
your app.
Alex, do you want to say something?
>>Alex: I have in the past written some very
bad code when I was learning how to use cursors
and it was apparent that sqlite isn't amazing
at type safety which means if there- even
if there is no way to check, to pull ranges
of blob data you might be able to treat it
as a string and then pull a sub string.
This would only be really useful if it was
between one and two megabytes.
I would say try to pull the first half of
the blob as a substring and then try to pull
the second half-
>>Trevor: But then you'd still have a string
that's larger than megabyte
>>Alex: as a substring.
Would you?
If the cursor- if the sql query itself only
returned like the first half of the blob-
>>Trevor: There you go.
>>Alex: Right?
I don't know if this would work.
This is sort of a last ditch thing that I
would try before giving up completely.
Also I would say Trevor's probably right,
you might have to take the nuclear approach
but I would recommend also being sure to build
in an option or build in a migration of path
for users who haven’t hit a one megabyte
row yet so that their stuff can be migrated
safely and they don't have to have anything
disappear unnecessarily.
>>Joe: That's a good point.
Thanks.
>>Trevor: Another thing you might be able
to do to rather than building in a full copy
of sqlite since you know specifically what
you're trying to get at, you might be able
to go and just look up the docs on the sqlite
website as to how their file format is structured.
It is a database and it's gonna be a bit complicated
but you might actually just be able to go
and read the data doc manually without going
to all the trouble of porting sqlite.
That might be easier and that's probably what
I'd try first
>>Alex: Yeah.
>>Joe: OK, thank you, gentlemen.
Anything else?
No?
Alright, next question is from Jehudi in Colombia.
"Is it possible to set a proxy to all the
system from my app?
If can be done without root even better, on
Chrome you have a very nice API for this"
and then he quotes the API link.
>>Trevor: This question comes up periodically
and as far as I can remember the answer is
actually no.
As a application developer there is no way
to go and set a proxy.
I believe it can be set- can it be set via
DHCP?
Yeah, in any case as an app developer that's
not available to you regardless.
Now what you can do is create a VPN provider
and implement your proxy as a VPN service.
Implementing a VPN provider requires a bunch
of special permissions and the user will get
a very scary warning which basically says
your app's going to have access to all data
and press no unless you're absolutely, positively
sure this app's trusted.
So writing a VPN provider isn't something
to take lightly.
But if this is something you absolutely need
to do, that's probably the best way to go
and intercept network traffic and to note
off to a proxy.
Keep in mind also that Android devices are
pretty mobile and if you're trying to do this
to make something work in a corporate environment
you have to consider what happens when the
user's phone switches over to a different
Wi-Fi network or it switches over to 3G.
What happens if it switches network while
they're in the building?
Maybe they just have a weak connection; the
phone decides that it likes the mobile network
better than your Wi-Fi, right?
Relying on proxies on mobile devices tends
to not work so well.
>>Joe: OK
>>Trevor: Just keep that in mind with whatever
you wind up doing.
>>Joe: Alright, next question.
This is from Hidden Android in Croatia.
"Should (and I think actually he means can)
devices with back-lit hardware keys turn the
lights off using an API call?
I have an HTC One X and the lights are controlled
only through a sensor.
This is making astronomy apps where dark adaptation
is needed impossible."
>>Trevor: So there is an API called the go
and hide the bottom row of buttons on your
device ability.
Is that called the system bar, right?
>>Alex: Yeah.
>>Trevor: So you can go and- you know we like
to call it light sack mode but you can either
make those buttons dim down to small little
dots.
So say you're doing something full screen
like a game and you don't want to go and bother
the user or any book reader, is actually probably
even a better use case.
And then also another mode that you can take
it even further that will and hide everything
completely.
So YouTube is the good example of where that's
done.
The catch being is when you completely hide
the system bar, any user interaction with
the screen will bring it back.
Cause the user does need to have a way to
get back to the home button, it's very important.
Now I’m not sure what the implementation
is on the HTC One X and I believe that's actually
something that's left up to HTC how they want
to implement.
But if there is a way to turn off those lights,
that would be the way to do it.
So in any case you shouldn’t be designing
just for that one particular phone.
So if having these extra controls on screen
is an issue, you might want to go and dim
the system bar regardless.
>>Alex: I actually interpreted the question
as there being a hardware keyboard.
>>Joe: Yeah.
>>Trevor: Oh so not just the home button.
>>Alex: But backlit like a G One or something
with backlit keys.
>>Trevor: OK, I don't think there's a separate
API call for that.
If there is a way it would probably be the
same one as the system bar.
>>Alex: Right.
>>Trevor: Yeah, I don’t think there's any
way- anything that actually controls keyboard
lighting.
>>Joe: OK, next question.
This is from Anuj who's in Mumbai in India
obviously.
"How many more years will it take to sell
apps on Google Play from India?
Can you give some answer other 'we are working
on it'?
It's been years, we getting the same reply.
Does Google want Indian developers to develop
free apps only forever?"
>>Trevor: OK, so in general we wanna go and
offer the ability to go buy and sell paid
apps, globally.
Of course, it's important to developers and
it's important for users to have a wide range
of applications available to them.
That said, the world's a very large, very
complicated place and trying- and then whenever
you have money involved, things get even more
complicated.
We're trying to go and offer these services
to everyone as quickly as we can.
Some places are taking us longer than others.
Unfortunately, I can't speak to the road map
as to when anything will happen.
It's the same as anything else having to do
with the Android road map; we just can't talk
about it on the air here.
So all I can say is be patient, we're trying
to get to everywhere as quickly as we can.
And hopefully we'll get to India soon, but
again I actually honestly don't know the answer,
but if I did I couldn't actually tell you
any specifics.
>>Joe: OK thanks, and I think the answer pretty
much is Google does not want Indian developers
to develop free apps only forever.
So we are surely working on it for every country.
>>Trevor: Right.
>>Joe: Next question is from Akhil in Ashburn,
Virginia.
"Is there a support library for the calendar
contract content provider?
I see that is supported from SDK 14 and upwards."
>>Trevor: No. [chuckles] So that's not something
I believe we can actually offer via the support
library because it would require elevated
permissions, it needs be able to read from
the calendar data based on the phone.
So the only service that can provide that
is the calendar application itself.
So short of having a new version of the calendar
that you've downloaded from Google play, which
doesn't really make much sense in that case
since it's one of the system apps which we
always update via OTA.
Yeah, there is really not any way to go and
load that new code on there.
So short answer the only way that can be done
is via OTA.
>>Joe: Alright, thank you.
Another question about the market or Google
play services or I'm sorry, Google play store.
From Danny in the Netherlands "How long should
it take before an app is back on the market
after the complaining party of a trademark
infringement has mailed Google the app can
go back?
It's been waiting for 16 days and counting."
>>Trevor: 16 days is definitely-
>>Dan: Before we go on,Joe, can you adjust
your mic to make sure it's not rubbing against
your collar too much?
I'm getting a little feedback from you.
>>Joe: OK.
>>Trevor: 16 days is definitely on the long
side, that's said I'm not sure what the specifics
are in your particular case.
What I'd recommend in this case is send us
an email via Google Plus or you know directly
to our account.
Feel free to send it to me or Android developers.
I'm Trevor Johns, Android developers is Android
developers, of course.
Make sure you let us know the name of your
application and then the ticket number you
have when you contacted support and we can
find out why this has taken so long.
Again, 16 days, that's much longer than I'd
expect it to take but I'm not sure why.
It's possible that there's some missing information
or it possibly got routed to the wrong address.
In fact even sure if it was submitted via
email or via postal mail, so there's a lot
of information that we're not sure just based
on your question.
Send us more details; we'll get to the bottom
of it for you.
>>Joe: OK, thanks.
Question from Shane in Wisconsin.
"Is there anywhere to get more information
regarding an update to the Android SDK for
Google Maps or just someone to contact about
the possibility of it?"
>>Trevor: So, we're aware that developers
want this; I don't think you need to contact
us to tell us.
We know developers want more features in the
maps SDK.
That said, just like the previous question
on India, we can't talk about the road map
on air.
So we can't actually tell you what, if anything
is happening with this.
But again, we are very much aware that developers
want an updated maps SDK.
>>Alex: I would also add places to watch for
updates Android Developers Plus page and the
Android Developer blog.
>>Trevor: YES.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Alex: Are the first two places that we will
post when, if and when, updates to the Maps
SDK go live.
>>Trevor: And Reto's show, too.
>>Alex: And Reto's show.
>>Trevor: So yeah, I believe it's every Monday
Reto Meier does a quick, it's 5 minutes, I
think?
A quick few minute update on what's new in
the Android world.
So if you prefer video content, you are watching
a video show right now, of course, that's
certainly and good place to go.
Three locations: Google Plus, Google Developer
blog and This Week in Android on YouTube.
So that'd be on the Android developers channel.
>>Joe: OK, so that covers all the questions
we had this week in moderator and I'm assuming
since Daniel hasn't been urgently waving his
hands in the corner that we don't have anybody
in the Hangout asking questions.
>>Trevor: Yeah, I think if there's no more
questions.
>>Joe: Alright, we will bore you no longer.
>>Trevor: Alright.
>>Joe: Please send your questions in and contact
us and having said all of that, thank you,
Chirag, and thank you, Tim, who's probably
not online anymore.
Thank you Alex and Trevor and Daniel and-
>>Trevor: Actually one more thing before you
sign off.
>>Joe: He's always like that.
>>Trevor: I always have a last word to fit
in there.
I don't know if you guys watching saw the
post we made yesterday or not, but we're trying
something new with this show.
We're trying to get people to go to send us
video questions in advance that way if you're
not in our time zone to join us live, you
can actually go and record a actual video
segment we can play on the air.
So everyone can participate.
But also will give us more time to formulate
answers for the more tougher questions you
guys send into us.
We still have the Moderate queue available,
we still are taking live questions, but we're
really encouraging people try sending us video
questions.
Please make sure you do it at least 24 hours
before the show so that way we have a chance
to go and get you nice well prepared answers.
The format for sending us video questions,
just go to Google Plus and click on the share
button and there's an attach video link down
there in the corner.
And there's an option to just record video
from your webcam.
So, record a video, ask your question, address
it to the Android Developers account and we'll
go ahead and look through those and play them
on the air just like any other questions.
So give it a try, it is a new thing, we're
not sure how well it will work so we're definitely
interested in your feedback.
Hopefully it works out well and you guys like
it.
So with that said, I think now we can sign
off.
>>Joe: OK, we can sign off.
>>Trevor: Thanks, everyone see you next week.
>>Joe: See you soon.